mieux des années 80 à l'exception donc
dans ton x démission que faisait grichka
et igor avec son frère qui leur a tout à
l'heure ses deux jumeaux il faut le
savoir c'est pas d'eux mêmes personnes
et éviter une émission sur la science
fiction qui s'appelle temps x vrai
qu'ils habitent en x d'ailleurs je vais
faire la première le tout premier
démarrage de temps avec sa première
émission en direct sur tf1
c'était vers le 21 avril à et milieu des
années 80 et alors ça commence comme ça
ces mots bienvenue à 10 sinon je regarde
la caméra et messieurs vous prenez des
décharges électriques on vous parlait
[Rires]
lunettes en fait alors dites-moi donc
oui vous démarrez bienvenue à tous dans
x c'est votre magazine le magazine de
tous ceux qui s'intéressant à la science
souhaitant découvrir certains aspects et
là les membres répartis pendant dix ans
et pendant ce milieu d' aventure au
moment où nous avons effectivement été
pratiquement au sommet de notre entre
guillemets réussite sur tf1 ouais voilà
que nous sommes amenés à aller à
pinewood donc en hélicoptère il vraiment
la chance d'être pilote d'hélico donc
sonné partir j'ai décroché et mines
[Rires]